If you would only let me, I could be a different version of your dad I'm twice as funny, and also twice as sad I know just what not to say, but it's a game you already know how to play Fan the flame and stoke the hay Bake the little figures from our clay You'll never know, dear, just quite what we did Hand in hand and don't you frown You and I are something like love Something of love
如果你愿意的话，我可以成为你父亲的另一个版本 我风趣两倍，也悲伤两倍 我深知什么话不该说，但这是一场你早已轻车熟路的游戏 扇动火焰，拨弄干草 用我们的黏土捏出小人儿 你永远不会明白，亲爱的，我们究竟做了什么 手拉手，别皱眉 你我之间，有些类似于爱 有关爱的事物
We can all be free, just don't look down If you can only let me I'll let you help me like you helped your mom I'll hold it against you but you can take that because you're strong Look at the stars loving what they are What are you love and what am I, eh? Where were we supposed to be? And oh Lord, love, ain't we far from that day? We ae locusts in the desert and lotus by the stream We chink the wood in the wind And tie our rafts in spring Another drink tastes like freedom But another drink won't set you free
我们都可以自由，只是别向下看 如果你只肯让我这么做 我会让你帮我，就像你帮过你妈妈一样 我会对此耿耿于怀，但你能承受，因为你很坚强 看看繁星，爱着它们本来的模样 你是什么爱，我又是什么爱，嗯？ 我们本来该去往何方？ 噢，上苍啊，爱，难道我们离那一天还不够远吗？ 我们是沙漠里的蝗虫，溪流旁的荷花 我们在风中填塞木头，在春天系好木筏 又一杯酒尝起来像自由 但另一杯酒并不能给你自由
Who are you love and who are we? Now that, that our parents set us free We wandered in the desert and we knelt by the stream We chink our cabins in the winter and tie our rafts in spring We forgot all the languages you taught us There was nothing there to say Instead we trace our symbols We learn the songs of lines in the sand You are bitter and broken You are constantly choking on bile
你是谁，爱，我们又是谁？ 既然，既然我们的父母给了我们自由 我们在沙漠中游荡，在溪流旁跪下 我们在冬天填塞木屋，在春天系好木筏 我们忘记了你教给我们的所有语言 当时无话可说 留下的只有我们描绘的符号 我们学习沙地上线条的歌谣 你痛苦且破碎 你不断地被胆汁噎住
We are not yours, there is nothing to discuss You have many debts to pay We put your wall into a thimble Tattooed your names onto our heads We are outside the door now I have their hide and key You're sleeping on a pile of ill-gotten games But you will not forget our names Come back to your crib now We burn the SUV We alchemize your money
我们不属于你，没有什么好讨论的 你有数不清的债要还 我们把你的墙塞进顶针 把你们的名字纹在我们的额头上 我们现在就在门外 我有它们的皮毛和钥匙 你正睡在一堆来路不正的游戏上 但你不会忘记我们的名字 回到你的婴儿床去吧 我们烧毁了SUV 我们将你的金钱炼金术化
Nothing remains The old boroughs dances in the flames Come back to bed baby It's time to settle down Hush now little one Look at the stars H hush hush now sleep. 24,000 BCE give or take 4,000 years. A piece of neural tissue called the Procuneus begins to grow and it bridges objective perception and subjective experience for the first time in evolutionary history. This isn't about
什么都没剩下 旧街区在火焰中起舞 回到床上来吧，宝贝 是时候安定下来了 嘘，小家伙 看看繁星 嘘，嘘，嘘，现在睡觉。 公元前24,000年前后，上下浮动4,000年。 一块被称为楔前叶的神经组织开始生长，在进化史上第一次将客观感知与主观体验连接起来。 这与
intelligence. Dolphins are smart, octopi solve puzzles, they have intelligence in the limbs and their bodies similar to insects, and the Procuneus is the piece of the brain that forms in humans that makes different parts of the brain observe one another and it also makes them argue and the problem is it also makes them aware that they exist somewhere around this time 24,000 BCE to 22,000 BCE, highly probably, but give or take you know some stuff. Someone drops a the Venus of Villendorf, the piece of stone we call the Venus of Villendorf now, into probably water somewhere in France.
智慧无关。 海豚很聪明，章鱼会解谜，它们的四肢和身体有着类似于昆虫的智慧，而楔前叶是人类大脑中形成的一个部位，它能让大脑的不同部分相互观察，还会让它们争吵，问题是，它也让它们意识到自己存在于某个地方，大约在这个时期，公元前24,000年到公元前22,000年，极有可能，当然也可能有些出入。 有人把维伦多尔夫的维纳斯——我们现在称之为维伦多尔夫维纳斯的这块石头，扔进了法国某处的水中。
30,000 BC cave bears are going extinct because these annoying new things that start to resemble humans start crawling into their homes to do rituals and not really the easy parts of the caves to access either which you'd think that a cave is just like a house made of stone that people go into to live, but for some reason we didn't. We went into the parts of the caves that were deepest chambers, really hard to access sometimes like across chasms and things. We went to the places in caves that had the best acoustic resonance. Where when you painted things on the walls and you chanted and it echoed, it sort of made a psychedelic effect as the fire turned the pictures sort of alive and the echoes became something like I don't know, psilocybin probably does now. They are sort of the first churches and the Scandinavian ice sheet still covers
公元前30,000年，洞熊正在走向灭亡，因为这些开始长得像人类的烦人的新生物，开始爬进它们的家园去举行仪式，而且去的可不是洞穴里那些容易进入的地方，你可能会认为洞穴就像一座石头房子，人们走进去是为了居住，但不知为何我们没有。 我们走进了洞穴最深处的房间，有时真的很难进入，比如穿过深渊之类的地方。 我们去了洞穴里声学共鸣最好的地方。 在那里，当你在墙上画画并吟唱时，它会产生回音，随着火焰让画作变得栩栩如生，回音会产生一种类似于——我不知道，大概就像现在赛洛西宾（致幻剂）产生的那样——的迷幻效果。 它们算是最早的教堂，而斯堪的纳维亚冰原仍然覆盖着
all of Europe. The Persian Gulf is dry land. It has cobalt blue lakes that look like jewels. Against the red sandstone there is no sand. And in this alien world someone drops a carved figure near Willendorf, the Venus of Willendorf. It's an obese and fertile goddess with her face hidden by braids or maybe a ritual mask. Some sort of texture. Why this is is up for debate. It's prehistory, so you kind of get to make things up as long as they don't violate things like carbon dating or archaeological discoveries You can sort of say why anyone did anything because no one was writing it down The Venus has no practical purpose. She's very large. She has big hips. She also has an exaggerated vulva or external vagina
整个欧洲。 波斯湾是一片陆地。 它有着像珠宝一样湛蓝的湖泊。 在红砂岩衬托下，根本看不到沙子。 在这个异世界里，有人在维伦多尔夫附近扔下了一个雕刻的人形，也就是维伦多尔夫维纳斯。 这是一个肥胖而多产的女神，她的脸被辫子或某种仪式面具遮住了。 某种质感。 至于为什么会这样，目前尚存争议。 这是史前时期，所以只要不违反碳测年或考古发现之类的东西，你基本上可以自行编造原因。 你可以说任何人做任何事的原因，因为当时没有人把它们写下来。 这个维纳斯没有任何实际用途。 她体型庞大。 她有着宽大的臀部。 她还有一个夸张的阴户或外阴
She's got big breasts and Why the face is covered yeah, she's got big breasts, and why the face is covered, yeah there's debate. Scholar John Dominic Crisson would later write, ancient people told stories symbolically, and I'm not saying that we are now smart enough to decode these symbols, I'm saying that now we are stupid enough to take them literally he said that in quite a few talks and some of his books some variation of that The precuneus the piece of the brain that I start describing it had given us this problem. We could now perceive time Identity and sort of primitive morality like a deer doesn't know that it will die. We do
她有着巨大的乳房，至于为什么脸被遮住，是的，她有着巨大的乳房，至于为什么脸被遮住，是的，这存在争议。 学者约翰·多米尼克·克里森后来写道，古代人以象征的方式讲述故事，我并不是说我们现在足够聪明去解码这些符号，我是说我们现在愚蠢到把它们照单全收。他在不少演讲和一些书里都说过类似的话。 楔前叶，我开始描述的那块大脑区域，给我们带来了这个麻烦。 我们现在能够感知时间、身份以及某种原始道德，比如一鹿并不知道自己会死。而我们知道
Joseph Campbell said of all religion that it is about tolerating guilt and shame and Jung would later call this the shadow the parts Of ourself that we can't really bear to acknowledge because they fill us with guilt and shame they're out modern therapy would say that they are things that are outside of our window of tolerance or what we can bear. But the problem with the precuneus is it made us aware of multiple things that had existed in the brain before for a long time. But now we could perceive them. There's a huge difference in perceiving information versus processing it. Before we had been processing information to act on things like
约瑟夫·坎贝尔曾评价所有宗教，说它们都是关于容忍负罪感和羞耻感的，而荣格后来将这称为阴影——我们内心深处那些实在不忍承认的部分，因为它们让我们充满了负罪感和羞耻感，它们在现代疗法看来，是超越了我们的容忍窗口或我们所能承受极限的事物。 但楔前叶的问题在于，它让我们意识到了大脑中很久以前就存在的多种事物。 但现在我们可以感知它们了。 感知信息与处理信息有着巨大的差异。 以前，我们一直在处理信息，以对诸如
light and relational information about what other things like us were feeling or you know community the sort of the way that fish will react when they form a school they're not really thinking about what they're doing but they're aware of what the other fish do. The Procuneus bridged these subjective and objective networks in a way that became problematic because what it did was it let us know that these parts of the brain were there and it let them talk and it let them fight. And so when that happens, everything becomes a problem that has to be solved by something else like a religious sense of wholeness or a greater reality. Because even if I'm happy, I'm aware of time. I
光线以及关于我们同类感受的关联信息做出反应，或者说社区——就像鱼群形成鱼群时的反应方式那样，它们其实并没有思考自己在做什么，但它们意识到其他鱼在做什么。 楔前叶以一种变得有些问题的方式桥接了这些主观和客观网络，因为它所做的是，它让我们知道大脑的这些部分在那里，并让它们对话，让它们争吵。 于是，当这种情况发生时，一切都变成了必须由其他事物来解决的问题，比如宗教式的完整感或更大的现实。 因为即使我很快乐，我也意识到了时间。 我
may not be happy five minutes from now. I may not have been happy before. Why did that happen? It's not a good thing. You know, I'm aware of things like other people having an experience that's outside of myself and that experience may be being different from mine and maybe the things that I need are something that they don't want but I need them to give me which now makes me feel guilty and ashamed unless I repress it on and on and on. It makes networks of the brain that compete for the information that they prefer to process and the way that they prefer to process it now in communication with each other and these
可能从现在起五分钟就不快乐了。 我以前可能也不快乐。 为什么会这样？这不是一件好事。 你知道，我意识到了诸如其他人也有独立于我之外的体验，而这种体验可能与我的不同，也许我需要的东西是他们不想要的，但我需要他们给我，这现在让我感到内疚和羞耻，除非我把它压抑下去，没完没了。 它使得那些为了争夺自己倾向于处理的信息以及倾向于处理的方式而竞争的大脑网络，现在开始彼此沟通，而这些
networks had never really talked before. A million years later we get the Venus of Willendorf dropped into a puddle. Cut to Vienna 1909. Two men sit in a cafe. One is Sigmund Freud. He's kind of coked up, probably, and convinced that his sexual theories explain everything. The other one is Carl Jung, Freud assist mentor. And he's watching his mentor transform into everything that Carl Jung has been told by his mentor, Freud Freud that Freud opposes. Basically, Freud's becoming a religious zealot. He's saying, you were supposed to carry the fire against all of them. And Jung says, well, I'm a scientist. I'm trying to explore what works and what doesn't. And Freud says, no, you are going to create a bulwark. And Jung says to Freud,
网络以前从未真正交流过。 一百万年后，维伦多尔夫维纳斯被扔进了一个水坑里。 镜头切到1909年的维也纳。 两个男人坐在一间咖啡馆里。 一个是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。 他大概吸了点毒，并且坚信他的性理论可以解释一切。 另一个是卡尔·荣格，弗洛伊德的助手兼导师。 他正看着自己的导师变成卡尔·荣格一直被导师弗洛伊德告诫要反对的一切。 基本上，弗洛伊德正在变成一个宗教狂热分子。 他说，你应该肩负起对抗所有人的火种。 而荣格说，嗯，我是一个科学家。 我在尝试探索什么可行，什么不可行。 弗洛伊德说，不，你要筑起一道壁垒。 荣格对弗洛伊德说，
a bulwark against what? And Jung is told by Freud, a bulwark against what and Jung is told by Freud a bulwark against all of the people who will tell you that this is not sexual that it is not about sexuality. Promise me Freud says that you will make sexuality the bulwark of psychoanalysis no matter what else is discovered and Jung is stunned. This atheist scientist is now demanding faith, not evidence, and so protection from occultists is what Jung, or Freud is accusing everyone else of being occultists, saying you have to believe this despite the evidence that may later emerge, and Jung is saying that sounds kind of like the occult. Jung would later get into the occult, that's an aside. Anyway,
筑起什么壁垒？ 弗洛伊德告诉荣格筑起什么壁垒，弗洛伊德告诉荣格，要筑起一道壁垒，抵御所有那些会告诉你这不是关于性、这与性无关的人。 答应我，弗洛伊德说，无论后来发现什么，你都要让性成为精神分析的壁垒。而荣格惊呆了。 这个无神论科学家现在要求的是信仰，而不是证据，因此弗洛伊德指责其他人是神秘主义者，是在寻求对神秘主义者的保护，弗洛伊德说，尽管以后可能会出现证据，你也必须相信这一点，而荣格则说，这听起来有点像神秘主义。 荣格后来确实涉足了神秘主义，这是题外话。 总之，
Jung would later get into the occult, that's an aside. Anyway, he is watching Freud tell on himself by speaking in the language of a priest, not a scientist, and not even really an atheist, which is what Freud continued to maintain that he was. They had been arguing about a dream that Jung had at age 10. And in the dream Jung descends through a house. There's rococo furniture, but then slowly those modern trappings give away to medieval stone. And then underneath the medieval there is Roman walls, and then there is a cave that is filled with ancient skulls and pottery shards and layer after layer of history that is buried in the psyche. And Freud's interpretation of this dream is that like Jung wants to kill Freud as a father and then have sex with his mother, and Jung's
荣格后来确实涉足了神秘主义，这是题外话。 总之，他看着弗洛伊德用牧师而非科学家的语言，甚至也不是真正无神论者的语言（弗洛伊德一直坚称自己是无神论者）来暴露自己的本质。 他们一直在争论荣格10岁时做过的一个梦。 在那个梦中，荣格穿过一座房子。 那里有洛可可风格的家具，但随后那些现代的装饰慢慢让位给中世纪的石头。 在中世纪石头的下方是罗马墙，然后是一个充满古代头骨和陶器碎片的洞穴，这是埋藏在心灵深处的历史，一层又一层。 弗洛伊德对这个梦的解释是，荣格就像是想杀死身为父亲的弗洛伊德，然后和自己的母亲发生性关系，而荣格
polite disagreement is that no, the dream I think means that there are evolutionary layers of the mind that are beneath the personal, that are beneath the thing that may have anger or resentment or even romantic attraction to your parents. I think there are things that are older. There is a collective unconscious that we all share. This is a split that will tear psychoanalysis apart until it becomes Freudian psychoanalysis and what we call depth psychology now. So cut back to Jung's childhood.
礼貌的异议是，不，我认为这个梦意味着在个人之下、在那些可能对父母怀有愤怒、怨恨甚至浪漫吸引力的事物之下，存在着心灵的进化层。 我认为有更古老的东西。 我们所有人共享一个集体无意识。 这是一个将撕裂精神分析的分裂，直到它演变成弗洛伊德精神分析以及我们现在所说的深度心理学。 所以，让我们回到荣格的童年。
Here's what Freud never understood. Not everyone has the same father wound. Freud was watching his father be weak, be passive, fail to exemplify the warrior, fail to be the authority that Freud needed as a child, the powerful figure. And so Freud navigated to powerful figures that he made into father figures from ancient history until he could find some in life like brewer and fleece. And so Freud spent his whole life
这就是弗洛伊德从未真正理解的事情。 并不是每个人都有相同的父亲创伤。 弗洛伊德看着自己的父亲软弱、被动，无法成为战士的楷模，无法成为弗洛伊德童年时期所需要的权威、强大的形象。 因此，弗洛伊德转向了那些强大的形象，把他们从历史长河中塑造成父辈形象，直到他在生活中找到像布罗伊尔和弗利斯这样的人。 所以弗洛伊德花了一生时间
trying to become this strong father and then destroying anyone who challenged his authority as that thing that was this impossible myth he was trying to be while he was also bleeding an atheist that didn't believe in mythology outside of some kind of reductionist metaphor to an edible complex or relationship with wanting to have sex with your mom and kill your dad. And so Jung's father was different.
试图成为这样一个强大的父亲，然后摧毁任何挑战他作为这种权威形象的人——这是一个他试图成为的不可能的神话，同时他自己还流着一个不相信神话的无神论者的血，除了将神话贬低为俄狄浦斯情结或想跟妈妈做爱、想杀死爸爸的某种还原论隐喻。 所以，荣格的父亲是不同的。
Paul Jung was a Swiss pastor and he had lost his faith but he had to keep preaching to pay the bills. He felt guilty about this. It was sort of an open secret to anyone who knew him well. And he saw himself as a fraud. And Jung, Carl Jung, didn't want to kill his father. He wanted to save him. And so Jung develops this radical idea pretty early in his subconscious and then later it manifests in more of his literal mind through dreams and he makes it as a psychology to bring to his father as a gift. What if religion isn't literally true or false?
保罗·荣格是一位瑞士牧师，他失去了信仰，但为了付账不得不继续传道。 他为此感到内疚。 这对任何了解他的人来说几乎是一个公开的秘密。 他觉得自己是个骗子。 而荣格，卡尔·荣格，并不想杀死他的父亲。 他想拯救他。 于是荣格在潜意识中很早就发展出了这个激进的想法，后来它通过梦境更多地表现在他字面的思维中，他把它作为心理学作为礼物带给他的父亲。 如果宗教在字面上并非绝对的真理或谬误，会怎样呢？
What if that's a binary that is one about a pre-scientific mind fighting with the modern science of the time mind and that there is sort of a third age where we transcend these things and see their real purpose as competing networks in the brain. They both have a place but neither one of them can define our humanity. And you would take Jung a lifetime to articulate something that sounded sort of like that. Other people later after Jung like Edinger would help him maybe flesh those ideas out, but I believe that's broadly what he was trying to say. And so if we claim we're not religious we just repress this religious function. And so like Freud who's turning atheism into a dogma and like a lot of people now that turn empiricism or science into a religion in
如果那是一个二元对立，一方是前科学思维在与当时的现代科学思维做斗争，而存在着某种第三个时代，在这个时代里我们超越了这些东西，看到了它们作为大脑中竞争网络的真实目的。 它们都有各自的一席之地，但它们谁也无法定义我们的人性。 荣格花了一生时间才阐明了听起来有点像这样的观点。 荣格之后的其他人，比如埃丁格，或许曾帮助他充实这些想法，但我相信这大体上就是他试图表达的意思。 因此，如果我们宣称自己不信教，我们只是压抑了这种宗教功能。 于是就像把无神论变成教条的弗洛伊德一样，就像现在许多把经验主义或科学变成某种无法以此方式运作的宗教的人一样，你知道，什么是，投射、宇宙学以及人类思考方式有着心理学上的必然性。 荣格对这一点感到坦然，而弗洛伊德则不然。 荣格带着他为父亲制作的这份礼物去拯救父亲。 他不想像弗洛伊德那样去杀死、废黜或贬低父亲并取代他。 他想治愈他的父亲，因为他作为一个孩子感受到了父亲的创伤，并以与弗洛伊德处理自身创伤不同的方式处理了那个父亲创伤。 弗洛伊德无法想象任何人会与他不同，这就是为什么他把所有的心理学都归结为他自己的阴影。 不幸的是，这份礼物并没有奏效，就像上帝背弃了保罗·荣格（荣格的父亲），或者
a way it can't function as that, you know, what is, there is a psychological inevitability to projection, to cosmology and how humans think. And Jung was comfortable with this in a way that Freud was not. Jung brings this gift that he makes to his father in order to save the father. He didn't want to kill or dethrone or discredit the father and replace him in the way that Freud did. He wanted to heal his father because he sensed his father's woundedness as a child and handled that father wound differently than Freud did handle his own. Freud couldn't really conceive of anybody being different from him which is why he reduces all of psychology based down to his own shadow. Unfortunately this gift doesn't work just as God has turned his back on Paul Jung, Jung's father, or
也许保罗·荣格背弃了上帝，这取决于你站在什么立场，保罗·荣格也背弃了他儿子的礼物，并说，不，这是亵渎神明。这是错的。他无法看透自身的失败，而荣格试图帮他将缺乏信仰与可能包容他怀疑的更广阔的宇宙学或心理学调和起来，却成了一个只会提醒他自身羞耻的问题。 在弗洛伊德和荣格决裂后的职业生涯后期，荣格可能——我认为——会写下他的心理类型理论，作为向弗洛伊德道歉的一种方式，以便这位父亲形象或许能有与保罗·荣格不同的
maybe Paul Jung has turned his back on God, depending on where you're standing, Paul Jung also turns his back on his son's gift and says, no, this is blasphemous. It's wrong. He can't see past his own failure and Jung trying to help him reconcile his lack of faith with a broader cosmology or psychology that might be inclusive of his doubt becomes a problem that only reminds him of his own shame. Later in the career after the split between Freud and Jung, Jung would probably, I think, write his theory of psychological types as a way of apologizing to Freud so that the father figure could maybe have a different
经历，并从他儿子试图道歉和调和这两种思维方式的尝试中看到一丝真理。 弗洛伊德从来没有接受过他在他们不再联系时通过出版这部作品所表达的这一提议，但弗洛伊德绝对阅读了荣格写的一切，以便对它说三道四。 所以，如果荣格知道他读了，弗洛伊德也绝没有接受他关于求同存异、妥协、更广阔心理学的提议，就像他父亲一样。 荣格在余生中基本上是孤独的。 他有喜欢他所做的事情的信徒。 他喜欢其中的几个人。 除了在《红书》中写的内容之外，他再也没有真正找到过父亲形象。 但我不是想谈
experience than Paul Jung did and see some kernel of truth in his son's attempt to apologize and reconcile both modes of thinking. Freud never takes him up on this offer that he makes by publishing this work when they're no longer in contact, but Freud is definitely reading everything that Jung writes in order to talk shit about it. So if Jung knows that he read it, Freud doesn't take him up on his offer of agree to disagree, compromise, broader psychology, any more than his father did. Jung was fundamentally alone for the rest of his life. He has disciples who like what he's doing. He likes a couple of them. He never really finds a father figure after Freud except maybe in what he writes in the Red Book. But I'm not trying to talk
太多关于荣格的事。 我不是想预设你对他的了解太多。 所以我将回到荣格关于上帝的那个梦境序列。 荣格还是个孩子的时候，他对这座美丽的宏伟建筑赞叹不已。 它金碧辉煌，雕梁画栋，完美无缺。 他想知道什么样的上帝才能住在这样的笼子里。 一定是这个美妙的上帝，被包含在
too much about Jung. I'm not trying to presuppose that you know too much about him. So I'll just go back to this dream sequence that Jung has about God. Jung, as a kid, he's marveling at this beautiful cathedral. It's golden, it's ornate, it's perfect. And he wonders what kind of God could live in such a cage. It must be this wonderful God that is contained
荣格看到的这座辉煌大教堂里，你知道的，根据梦境的写法，（你知道的）从上方俯瞰，（你知道的）从侧面看着它，（你知道的）在它的外面，突然云开雾散，然后一团巨大的屁股从云层中露出来，据推测那是上帝的屁股，粪便从天而降，摧毁了教堂。 它们砸碎了镀金的窗户，
in this brilliant cathedral that Jung is seeing, you know, presumably in the way the dream is written, you know, from above, you know, he's looking at it from the side, you know, outside of it, and all of a sudden the clouds part, and then a big ass comes out of the clouds, presumably God's ass, and turds rain from heaven and they destroy the church. They smash the gilded windows,
它们砸碎了所有这些东西，荣格在梦中仿佛觉得上帝的屁股在说，我不在这里，我比这更大，我在它上面拉屎，上帝在说，这种金色的字面主义并不是我居住的地方。 我是你内心活生生的过程。 我比教堂还要宏大，这仍然是一个充满争议的想法。 所以镜头切到维也纳咖啡馆。 切回，或者说回到。 荣格提到这家博物馆在宣传木乃伊展览，就像我们在第一集里讨论的沼泽木乃伊一样。 在他的梦里，这些木乃伊象征着
they smash all of these things, and Jung sort of feels in his dream like the ass pole of God is saying, I don't live here, I'm bigger than this, I shit upon it, and God is saying, this golden literalism is not where I live. I am this living process inside of you. I am bigger than the church, which remains a controversial idea. So cut to the Vienna Cafe. Cut back to, rather. Jung mentions this museum is advertising mummy exhibits, like we talked about in the first episode, the bog bodies. And in his dreams, these mummies symbolize
原型内容是如何在无意识中沉睡却得以保存的，你知道的倒吸了一口凉气，脸色变得惨白，倒在地上昏迷不醒。 荣格说，你没事吧？ 弗洛伊德没有进行反驳。 他们没有吵架，因为记住，弗洛伊德无法在任何人面前昂首挺胸。
how archetypal contents lie dead, but preserved in the unconscious, you know. And Freud gasps, and he turns white, and he faints to the floor. And Jung's like, are you okay? Freud doesn't make a counterargument. They're not in a fight, because remember, Freud can't stand up to anybody.
他在任何人面前都无法主张自己。 他是一个非常被动攻击的人。 他通常当面同意别人的观点，然后在背后说人坏话，或者像在给弗利斯的信中那样谄媚，然后后来又说，哦，不，不，不。 但是，你知道，哦，不，不，不，不，我其实不喜欢他，无论如何还是把人疏远了，我们在第一集里已经讲过了，但是记住，荣格不
He can't assert himself against anybody. He's a very passive aggressive person. He usually agrees with people to their face and then talk shit about them behind their back or he is sycophantic like in the Letter to Fleece and then later he says like, oh no, no, no. But, you know, oh no, no no no he i actually don't like him and cuts people off anyway we went through that in the first one but remember Jung doesn't
想杀死父亲，他想超越父亲，他想在科学与灵魂之间、在度量与神圣之间架起桥梁，而弗洛伊德对自身被压抑的无意识宗教性感到恐惧，因为它是被压抑的，他只能将此视为背叛，因为这不是他的主意，所以荣格因为没有通过让他成为完美的父亲来成为完美的儿子而失败了，于是弗洛伊德直接晕倒了。 爆发点出现在1912年荣格出版《无意识的心理学》时，弗洛伊德策划了将他逐出精神分析运动。 荣格进入了他所谓的与无意识的对峙时期，或者他事后所认为的一段接近精神错乱的时期，可以说是一种可控的精神错乱，当时荣格担心在被
want to kill the father he wants to transcend the father he wants to build bridges between the science and the soul between the measure and the numinous and Freud is terrified of his own unconscious religiosity because it's repressed and he can only see this as betrayal because this is not his idea and so Jung is failing to be the perfect son by making him the perfect father and so Freud just faints. The breaking point comes when Jung publishes The Psychology of the Unconscious in 1912 and Freud engineers his expulsion from the psychoanalytic movement. Jung enters what he calls his confrontation with the unconscious, or he would in hindsight a period of near psychosis, arguably contained psychosis, where Jung is afraid that he is going so mad after being
两个父亲抛弃后，自己会变得疯狂，甚至发展成精神分裂症。 所以他试图将这些精神错乱的探索限制在一个时间段内，在此期间他写下了后来被称为《红书》的东西，在结束了一整天的工作后，他在阁楼里依然是一个相当成功且清醒的医生。 他是一个善于将生活各个方面进行隔离的人。 他绝对是神经多元的。 这种自闭症谱系具体会是什么样子还有待讨论，他绝对是神经多元的。
abandoned by two fathers that he's going to develop schizophrenia. So he tries to contain these psychotic explorations to a time where he writes what would later be called the Red Book, and his attic, after working all day, is a fairly successful and sane doctor. He's a compartmentalized person. He's definitely neurodivergent. Exactly what that autism spectrum would look like is up for debate, He's definitely neurodivergent.
这种自闭症谱系具体会是什么样子还有待讨论，但荣格有一种将这些事情隔离开来的能力，他意识到这是不正常的。 他不希望《红书》成为其他人治愈的方法。 他希望它成为自己获得关于常年哲学、神秘主义传统以及心理学历史的智慧的一种方式，并以一种能够为主流精神分析实践提供参考的方式与阴影相遇，因为在放弃了拯救父亲之后，荣格决定拯救自己，所以荣格没有像弗洛伊德那样压抑这些幻象，而是做了一件激进的事情。 他深入其中。 他记录它们。 他画下它们。 《红书》美极了。
Exactly what that autism spectrum would look like is up for debate, but Jung has an ability to compartmentalize these things in a way that he realizes is abnormal. He doesn't want the Red Book to be a method that everyone else heals. He wants it to be a way that he gains wisdom into perennial philosophy and mystical traditions and the history of psychology And an encounter with the shadow in a way that could inform mainstream psychoanalytic practice Because he wants to be braver than Freud after giving up on saving the father Jung decides to save himself And so instead of repressing these visions like Freud would have and did, Jung does something radical. He descends into them. He records them. He paints them. The red book is beautiful.
里面有与各种形象的对话，比如荣格自己脑海和心灵内部的内在存在。 以利亚、莎乐美、菲勒蒙。 这不是疯狂，这是方法。 在这段旅程中，荣格发现弗洛伊德所描绘的个人无意识——当他说情感包含着现实、社会、人们的真正动机时——只是最表层。 但在这之下，是集体无意识，存在着全人类共享的模式和图像。 荣格在维也纳与患有精神分裂症、大多酗酒且受教育程度不高的患者合作时，无意中发现了后来成为原型理论的早期雏形，
There's dialogues within our figures like inner being inside of Jung's own head and psyche. Elijah, Solomé, Philemon. And this isn't madness, it's method. On this journey, Jung discovers that the personal unconscious that Freud mapped when he says that emotion, you know, contains the real motivation for reality, for society, for people, is just the top layer. But beneath that lies this collective unconscious, and there's patterns and there's images that are shared by all of humanity. Jung famously stumbled across the early proto, you know, what would become the theory of archetypes when he's working with patients that have schizophrenia and are largely alcoholic and uneducated in
他意识到这些人从来没有被教导过任何我所知道的神话知识。 使荣格成为一个如此高效的心理学家——或者我甚至不想说高效，而是超越性的、整合的、思想渊博的——的原因之一，是他受过极其深厚的教育。 他会说很多种语言，他让诸如弗朗茨这样的人帮他翻译他不会说的语言，以便这些内容仍能进入他的思想。 他对人类学、哲学、心理学都有着其他在这个领域工作的人所没有的深刻理解，这也使得荣格学派的疗法
Vienna and he realizes these people never were taught anything about the mythology that I know. One of the things that makes Jung such an effective psychologist, or I don't even want to say effective, but transcending, integrative, vast in his thought is that he's incredibly over-educated. He speaks a ton of languages, he has people like Frans Frans like translate languages that he doesn't speak for him so they can still enter his thought. He knows about anthropology, he knows about philosophy, he knows about psychology in a way that everyone else working in his field doesn't, and it still makes Jungian therapy
以及荣格本人成为了一种很难被谈论的语言。 但他注意到，这些精神分裂症患者——如果放到今天可能会说他们患有精神分裂症，他们也酗酒，且大多受教育程度不高。 他们没有任何正规训练。 他们甚至连母语都说不好，更不用说其他语言了。 他们连阅读都不会，更不用说阅读古希腊或波斯的古代神话了。 但他在他们的精神错乱中看到了他所熟悉的那些神话。 所以，如果你在梦见公牛与太阳交配，当你梦见琐罗亚斯德教或路西典神秘宗教时，这些东西可能并不是来自于你生活中的直接经历。 它们可能来自于某种演化历史，
and Jung himself a language that is very hard to speak. But what he notices is that these people who are schizophrenic, who might say today, or they have schizophrenia, they're also alcoholic, they're largely uneducated. They don't have any formal training. They don't even speak their native language well, let alone other languages. They don't know how to read, let alone read mythology from ancient Greece or Persia. But what he sees in their psychosis are myths that he's familiar with. So if you're dreaming about a bull mating with the sun, when you're dreaming about Zoroastrianism or Lucidian mystery cults, then these things might not be coming from your direct experiences in life. They may be coming from some sort of evolutionary history
这种历史是普遍存在的。 某种东西将神话联系在了一起。 荣格心理 psychotherapy 成为后来诸如比较宗教研究等学科的根源，这早已不是什么秘密。 尽管宗教中某些平行的相似之处被夸大了，因为宗教确实也有个人和文化的层面，但荣格是第一批做出这种区分的人之一，尽管像约瑟夫·坎贝尔、伊利亚·德尔切、维كتور·特纳，有时甚至罗伯特·摩尔，并没有将许多他们自己想出来的想法归功于荣格。 但对弗洛伊德来说，无意识
that is universal. There may be something that links mythology together. It's no secret that like Jungian psychotherapy becomes like the root of what would later become something like comparative religion. And even though some of those parallels in religion are overblown, because religion also does have a personal and cultural layer, Jung is one of the first people to make this distinction even though people like Joseph Campbell, people like Elie de Merche, Victor Turner, sometimes even Robert Moore don't give Jung credit for a lot of the ideas that they come up with themselves. But for Freud, the unconscious
不过是个下水道，我们在那里压抑了色欲，压抑了在弗洛伊德看来与性吸引力挂钩的攻击性。 但对荣格来说，它是创造力、治愈和意义的源泉。 目标不是征服它，而是与它建立联系。 因为如果我们与它建立联系，它就不会与我们分离；如果它不与我们分离，它就再也无法控制我们。 因此，荣格心理疗法的核心不是压抑，而是整合。 通过与无意识整合，我们获得了所有的原型：英雄、母亲、阴影、自体，以及它们之间的所有关系。 阴影与自体之间的关系，或自我-自体轴心，可以变成
was just this sewer where we repressed lust, where we repress the aggression that was tied to sexual attraction in Freud's mind. But for Jung, it is this wellspring of creativity, healing, meaning. The goal is not to conquer, but it is to relate to it. Because if we relate to it, it does not become separate from us, and if it is not separate from us, it no longer controls us. So not repression, but integration becomes the point of Jungian therapy. To integrate with the unconscious, we get all of these archetypes, the hero, the mother, the shadow, the self, and all of the relationships between them. The relationship between the shadow and the self, or the ego-self access, could become
类似于创造意义或认识上帝的过程，这取决于你所使用的语言和你所在的传统。 那么，为什么现在这很重要呢？ 荣格认为科学的客观性和宗教的主观性都只是半真半解。 它们是通过收集不同的信息来审视同一个问题的方法。 他并不认为一个是正确的，另一个是错误的。 如果你压抑这种宗教冲动或超越冲动——按照你的说法，即超越功能——你就会变得像弗洛伊德那样无意识地宗教化。 如果你压抑了逻辑的一面，那么你
something like the process of making meaning or of knowing God depending on the language you're speaking, the tradition that you're in. So why does this matter now? Jung saw scientific objectivity and religious subjectivity as both half truths. They were ways of looking at the same problem by collecting different information. He didn't see one is right and one is wrong. And to repress this religious impulse or transcendental impulse, transcendental function as you would say, you become unconsciously religious like Freud was becoming. You repress this, if you repress the logical side then you
就会变成那种，我不知道，神智学信徒，或者我们现在所说的悬浮在幻想中的新时代水仙。 荣格嘲笑了很多现在与他联系在一起的东西。 当他谈到后来演变成新时代运动的事物时，他说，好吧，当你有一堆人说，“哦，那是能量”时，这跟心理学有什么关系呢，这在理论上毫无用处？ 所以他其实并不喜欢很多空洞的语言，但他确实有一个
become this kind of, I don't know, theosophical, or we would call now like new age narcissist that's floating on fantasies. Jung makes fun of a lot of the stuff associated with him now. When he's talking about what would become later the New Age movement, he's like, well, when you have a bunch of people being like, oh, that's energy. What does that have to do with psychology that is theoretically useless? So he doesn't really like a lot of the empty language, but he does have a
严谨的——或者说尽可能严谨的——客观方法来研究主观体验。 类似于常年哲学。 是的，就像，我不能具体地，你知道，在试管里说不同类型的神话之间存在某种关系，但当我发现世界各地的人们一遍又一遍地偶然发现相同的想法，而他们被时间隔开，被距离隔开，他们之间没有任何影响，然而他们却触及了相同的原型和相同的想法，那么我知道这与
rigorous, or as rigorous as you can, objective method for studying subjective experience. Something like perennial philosophy. Yes, like, I can't specifically, you know, in a test tube say that there's a relationship between different types of myth, but when I find people who are all around the world that stumble across the same ideas over and over again, and they're separated by time, they're separated by distance, there is no influence between them, yet they hit on the same archetypes and the same ideas, then I know that that has something to do with
心理学有某种关系，因为以一种半客观的方式，我在收集研究同一事物的不同人群的独立数据。 然而，你无法跨越数百万年的时间来进行研究。 因此，荣格试图应用到心理学等领域的客观性中，将会存在一个主观的元素，而这种主观性正是荣格试图应用于心理学和神话学等领域的，这是至今仍在行业内发生或不再发生的一场争论。 尽管如果你接触过荣格，人们可能只会轻描淡写地认为他是一个相信原型集体无意识的怪胎。 如果你了解更多一点，你知道，人们会说，“哦，他就是那个相信集体无意识的家伙，现在我们在心理学101课堂上继续往下学。”如果你了解得更多，人们要么会曲解他，把他变成像乔丹·彼得森那样古怪的尼采式人物，要么更有可能把他变成那种在某些我们使用的事物（比如MBTI）上大致正确、但后来却沉迷于炼金术和伪科学的家伙。 那些都不是真正的荣格，要谈论这些都是些什么人需要好几集的时间，而且我不是在写传记，我是借此在写一部心理学的传记。
psychology because in a semi objective way, I'm collecting independent data on people studying the same thing. However, you can't do a research study across, you know, a million years. So there will be a subjective element to the objectivity that Jung is trying to apply to something like psychology and objectivity that Jung is trying to apply to something like psychology and mythology, a fight that the profession is still having or not having to this day. Even though if you encounter Jung at all, people are likely to just kind of say he's a weirdo that believes in archetypal collective unconscious. If you get anything, you know, people will say, oh, he's the guy that believed in a collective unconscious now moving on in your psychology 101 class. If you get more, people are either going to bastardize him and turn him into something like weird and Nietzschean like Jordan Peterson does, or they're more likely going to turn him into kind of the guy that was
所以说，现代神经科学足以证明荣格在很多时候是正确的。 去查查像奥扎尼加、约瑟夫·勒杜、安东尼奥·达马西奥这样的人，还有数百万其他人。 你知道，勒杜的研究表明了创伤是如何绕过语言的。 达马西奥绘制了荣格凭直觉感知到的那种存在-感觉-
sort of right about some things that we use like the MBTI, but then he became obsessed with alchemy and pseudoscience. None of those things is really who Jung was, and to have a conversation about who any of these people are would be multiple episodes, and I'm not writing a biography, I'm writing a biography of psychology with these. So modern neuroscience, suffice it to say, proves Jung right a lot of the time. Look up somebody like Ozaniga, like Joseph LeDoux, like Antonio de Masio, like a million others. You know, LeDoux's research shows how trauma bypasses language. De Masio maps the kind of being, feeling,
认知的演进过程，这种过程在很大程度上是人类大脑在表观上进化运作的方式，后来遇到了以前相互独立的自身大脑的不同部分，然后必须通过整合来解决这个问题，这正是荣格心理学的核心，而它最近才刚刚进入生物学领域。 但无论如何，我录过一些节目，在节目中我为人们不屑一顾荣格观点的做法进行了辩护，同时也指出了现代神经学在很大程度上借用了他的思想，
knowing progression that Jung intuited that was a lot of the way that the brain phenomenologically evolved to work and then later encountered different parts of itself that were previously separate networks and then had to solve that problem through integration, which is the point of Jungian psychology, which has recently entered biology. But anyway, I've recorded episodes where I defend the way that people write off Jung's ideas while also taking credit for them in modern neurology,
有太多内容了，我不想现在就此岔开话题。 现在，加扎尼加有这样一个观点，或者说不是观点，你知道，是这些证明了裂脑现象的案例研究，其中大脑的网络并非天生就是生物学固定的。 大脑中的不同网络可以转移到其他结构部位，因此单纯从结构上研究大脑其实并不准确，因为大脑的不同部分倾向于以某种特定的方式思考。
a whole lot, I want to digress about that now. Now, Gazaniga has this idea, or not idea, you know, these case studies that demonstrate this split brain phenomenon, where networks of the brain are not inherently biological. Different networks in the brain can move to other structural bits, so to study the brain structurally is not really right because pieces of the brain prefer to think a certain way.
但如果你把它切成两半或者切掉那些部分，这些网络就会四处移动。 它们会像这个生物计算机的其他部分一样进行殖民，这个生物计算机本来应该做一件事。 但当它意识到自己由于你切掉了它的部分而无法再访问该功能时，它就会将意识转移到其他区域，并殖民大脑中在结构上并非设计用来做某事的网络，然后强迫它去做这些事情，这很迷人，大概也是一集更长的内容。 但如果你理解其中的含义，如果你没有去看那些书的话，因为那些书很棒，读起来并不难，嗯，迈克尔·加扎尼加、约瑟夫·勒杜、安东尼奥·达马西奥，如果你想深入了解这些事物的神经生物学含义，去读读那些书吧。 但是，它们所做的是证实了荣格感受到的许多事情。 而荣格之所以被轻视，是因为人们觉得你不能靠凭感觉瞎扯来做科学。 结果证明，你还真可以，因为
But if you just cut it in half or cut those things off, those networks will move around. They will colonize like other parts of biological, this biological computer that are supposed to do one thing. But when it realizes that it doesn't have access to that anymore because you cut pieces of it off, it will move consciousness into areas and colonize networks of the brain that weren't designed structurally to do a certain thing and then force it to do those things, which is fascinating and also probably a longer episode. But if you understand the implications of that, and if you don't look it, because those books are great, they're not hard to read, um, Michael Gazniga, Joseph Ledoux, Antonio Damasio, read those if you want to get into some of the neurobiological implications of these things. But, like, what they do is validate a lot of the things that Jung felt. And Jung is written off because people are like, you can't do science by feeling shit. Well, it turns out you can, because
他一直都是对的 尽管他身上有很多奇怪的地方，而且尽管他在很多地方也犯过错误 正如一位研究人员所说，你可以将它打造为理解现代意识时“剔除冗余部分最少、最不具还原论色彩的透镜”。 但美国人其实无法接受这一点，正如T.S.艾略特所说，意识。 但美国人其实无法接受这一点。 正如T.S.艾略特所说，人类一次只能理解一点现实。 他们能够容忍一点生活，一点理解，但无法同时容忍全部。 荣格曾就英雄神话对美国发出过警告。 你知道，变得特殊是危险的。
he continues to be right Even though there's a lot of weird things about him and even though there's a lot of places where he was wrong You can create it as one researcher said, you know the best Non-reductive lens with the least superfluous parts to understand modern consciousness But America can't really handle that as TS Eliot said consciousness. But America can't really handle that. As T.S. Eliot said, humans can understand a little bit of reality at a time. They can tolerate a little bit of life, a little bit of understanding, but not all of it at once. Jung warned America about a hero myth. You know, it's dangerous to be special. It's dangerous
昭昭天命是危险的。 这也是不可避免的，我们应该把它理解为我们心理学的一部分，但如果你过度认同任何一个原型，它们就会将你与作为你一部分的其他原型隔离开来，从而将你毁灭。 它们被压抑，然后进入你的阴影，接着被极度投射出去。 当荣格的思想登陆美国海岸时，正值50世纪（50年代），当时有两种东西让这个文化感到恐惧。 一种是我们可能不仅仅是我们通过客观、品味、触觉、度量所能控制的东西。 另一种则是我们无论是否承认，其实都是有宗教信仰的。 所有这些事情都与1950年代的文化格格不入，那种文化希望你仅仅成为你的银行存款、
to manifest destiny. It's also inevitable and we should understand it as a part of our psychology, but if you over identify with any of the archetypes they destroy you by cutting you off from the rest of the archetypes that are also you. They get repressed and then go into your shadow and then hugely projected. When Jung's ideas hit American shores, it's the 50s and two things terrified the culture at that time. The idea that we might be more than what we can control by achieve, you know, objectively, taste, touch, measure. And then also that we're all religious whether we admit it or not. All of those things were sort of not compatible with the 1950s culture that wanted you to only be what was in your bank account,
你能买得起的东西、你能商品化的东西、你能客体化的东西，同时也希望你通过皈依某种宗教来决定信教与否 我们其实不想以一种类似于“它是一种帮助我们创造意义并保持清明——或者走向疯狂——的大脑功能”的方式去思考宗教 我们只想让宗教变成那种我们去那里吃吃百乐餐鸡肉、谈论任何事情的乡村俱乐部，或者我们选择加入的任何社交群体 我们只想让宗教变成那种我们去吃吃百乐餐鸡肉、谈论任何我们选择加入的社交群体的俱乐部，而且美国人希望无意识是可以被征服的。
what you could afford, what you could commodify, what you could objectify, and also the idea that you could be religious or not by like converting to a religion We didn't really want to think about religion in a way Like it was a function of the brain that was helping us make meaning and stay sane Or go insane We wanted religion to just be this sort of country club that we went to to like eat potluck chicken and talk about whatever Social group we went to to like eat potluck chicken and talk about whatever social group we chose to join and Americans wanted the unconscious to be conquerable.
你能负担得起什么，你能将什么商品化，你能将什么客体化，还有那种你可以通过皈依宗教来决定是否有宗教信仰的想法 我们其实并不想以那种方式去思考宗教 就像它是大脑的一种功能，在帮助我们寻找意义并保持理智 或者发疯 我们只希望宗教成为那种我们去吃百家乐鸡肉并谈论任何事情的乡村俱乐部 我们加入的任何社交群体去吃百家乐鸡肉并谈论我们选择加入的任何社交群体，美国人希望无意识是可以被征服的。
Jung said it's a dance partner. Americans wanted archetypes to be literal. Jung said they're metaphors. Americans wanted individuation to be a product and Jung said it's a lifelong process not a destination and not a thing that you can go out and buy. As Edward Daigler said we cannot perceive what we canonize and the citizen secures himself from wisdom with an icon. We can wear a giant cross while we carjack a car. A mega-jurch pastor who's worth tens of millions of dollars can tell you that Jesus wants you to bomb the Middle East. There's like an entire like long tradition of Americans saying that there was a Bronze Age Jewish Socialist who wants you to do whatever we do now. What does religion even mean at that point through those interpretive lenses? Again, to go back to the John Dominic Crissan quote, what he will end his talks with when
荣格说过，这是一个舞伴。美国人希望原型是字面意义上的。荣格则说它们是隐喻。美国人希望个性化成为一种产品，而荣格则说它是一个终生的过程，而不是一个目的地，也不是你可以外出购买的东西。正如爱德华·戴格勒所说，我们无法感知我们所神圣化的东西，公民用偶像来保护自己免受智慧的伤害。我们可以在劫车时佩戴一个巨大的十字架。一个身家数千万美元的大型教会牧师可以告诉你，耶稣希望你轰炸中东。美国人有一种悠久的传统，认为有一个青铜时代的犹太社会主义者希望你做我们现在做的任何事。通过这些解释性的镜头，宗教在那个时候到底意味着什么？再次回到约翰·多米尼克·克里桑的名言，他将如何结束他的演讲
he explains, this is John Dominic Crissan, the scholar, when he explains what these mystery cults meant, what mythology means, the functions that these served in ancient society, he'll say, I am not saying that these people did these things and took them literally, and we're now smart enough to understand them symbolically. What I am saying is that these people did these things as metaphors and understood them symbolically, and we are now stupid enough to take them literally. So people attack Jung still, you know, for being unscientific, you know, that you can't... but all of the ideas that are part of what later would become, you know, cognitive behavioral or like empirically based therapy are also metaphors that you can't put into a test tube either. Go ahead and suck your self-esteem out with a syringe and see how much you have.
他解释说，这是学者约翰·多米尼克·克里桑，当他解释这些神秘邪教的含义，神话意味着什么，这些在古代社会中发挥的功能时，他会说，我并不是说这些人做了这些事情并按字面意思对待它们，而我们现在足够聪明，可以象征性地理解它们。我要说的是，这些人把这些事情作为隐喻来做，并象征性地理解它们，而我们现在却愚蠢到按字面意思去理解它们。所以人们仍然攻击荣格，你知道的，因为他不科学，你知道的，你不能……但所有构成后来成为（你知道的）认知行为或基于经验的疗法的思想，也是你无法放进试管里的隐喻。去用注射器把你的自尊吸出来，看看你有多少。
You can't prove that a green light represents Daisy in The Great Gatsby. You can infer it because it's right. Therapy deals in metaphors and metaphors heal. The metaphors are inevitable in the way that we need to make meaning, but they're also scary to science because they aren't something that can be objectively proved. The nasin xb in the commercial for like nose cleaner, not cleaner what's it called, decongestant when I was a kid, the b would pop onto the screen it had this kind of antonanderas like voice and it would like tell you that when you had allergies from pollen you should go buy this nasal
你无法证明一盏绿灯在《了不起的盖茨比》中代表黛西。你可以推断出来，因为它是对的。治疗处理的是隐喻，隐喻可以疗愈。在我们需要创造意义的方式中，隐喻是不可避免的，但它们对科学来说也是可怕的，因为它们不是可以客观证明的东西。在我小时候，一个鼻腔清洁剂广告里的纳新xb，不是清洁剂，叫什么来着，减充血剂，那个b会跳到屏幕上，它有一种类似于安东尼奥·班德拉斯的声音，它会告诉你，当你对花粉过敏时，你应该去买这种鼻腔
decongestion and at the end the bee would read all of the side effects and one of the side effects that the bee would read really fast in the 90s when I was a kid was unfortunately we do not to completely understand why nasal necks works. Same with antidepressants, Same with Jungian analysis. We know it works but we can't always measure the way that it works. We know something works but we can't prove why. The discovery comes after the mechanism of action and when you're dealing with antipsychotics, when you're dealing or not antipsychotics, antidepressants or cancer drugs, you can usually figure out like why it is that the
减充血剂，在最后，这个b会宣读所有的副作用，而90年代我小时候，这个b读得飞快的副作用之一就是，不幸的是，我们并不完全理解鼻腔颈为什么起作用。抗抑郁药也是如此，荣格分析也是如此。我们知道它起作用，但我们并不总能衡量它起作用的方式。我们知道某些东西起作用，但我们无法证明原因。发现在行动机制之后，当你处理抗精神病药物时，当你处理或者不是抗精神病药物时，抗抑郁药或癌症药物，你通常可以弄清楚为什么
mechanism of action works, like what enzyme in the liver is doing a thing, what is inhibiting cell growth. When you're dealing with psychology, you can't always prove why it works with a direct mechanism of action, but you still can prove that it does, which is again a fight that we're still having. Jung writes, know all the theories, master all the techniques, but as you touch a human soul, just be another human soul. He also writes, of course there are places
作用机制起作用，比如肝脏中的哪种酶在起作用，什么在抑制细胞生长。当你处理心理学时，你并不总能用直接的作用机制证明它为什么起作用，但你仍然可以证明它确实起作用，这又是我们仍在进行的争论。荣格写道，了解所有理论，掌握所有技术，但当你触及一个人类灵魂时，只需成为另一个人类灵魂。他还写道，当然有些地方
where my theories contradict. I am making a system of mirrors to reflect the central fire back at you so that you can perceive its light. However, there are places where the mirrors overlap and there are gaps between the mirrors. Not everything that he says is consistent and it wasn't supposed to be because it's a metaphor for complex systems of cognition. And if you approach Jung like a philosopher, a logical positivist, you know, philosopher, and you're like, I'm going to listen
我的理论是矛盾的。我正在建造一个镜子系统，把中心之火反射回给你，这样你就能感知它的光芒。然而，镜子有重叠的地方，镜子之间也有空隙。他所说的话并非全都是一致的，而且本该如此，因为它是复杂认知系统的隐喻。如果你像一个哲学家、一个逻辑实证主义哲学家那样接近荣格，你知道的，然后你会想，我要去听
to all of his philosophical suppositions and then I'm going to try and disprove them then you are killing him you do not understand what he's trying to say so go read something else like go talk about if that's the kind of philosophy that you want to do like well in the Parmenides here's the six steps to disprove Plato's theory of forms like go do that diagram arguments and then become a lawyer don't become a psychotherapist dear God please but anyway fast forward to the 1960s the CIA starts dosing people with LSD because they're looking for the secrets of consciousness these ideas that Jung has kicked off about the limitless nature of the mind and how
他所有的哲学假设，然后我要试着反驳它们，那么你就是在杀死他，你并不明白他在试图表达什么，所以去看点别的，比如去讨论如果你想做那种哲学的话，就像在《巴门尼德篇》中一样，这里有六个步骤来反驳柏拉图的理念论，去那样做吧，画出论证的图表然后去当律师，别去当心理治疗师，上帝求你了，但无论如何，快进到20世纪60年代，中情局开始让人服用LSD，因为他们在寻找意识的秘密，荣格所开启的关于心灵无限性质的想法，以及
deep it might go and what it might connect to metaphysically have reached America and they're in the culture whether or not people know their mind and how deep it might go and what it might connect to metaphysically have reached America and they're in the culture. Whether or not people know their influences, Jung is a lot of their influences. Timothy Leary preaches to tune in and turn on and drop out and Fritz Perls develops Gestalt therapy. Wilhelm Reich is doing what would later become you know bio-energetics, somatic work. Everyone is trying to crack this code that Jung pointed towards, how to access the deeper layers of psyche without going insane, and also without trying to pretend that we, in our consciousness, is just a product of natural selection. Even if that is its origin, it was not its destination.
它可能有多深，它可能在形而上学上连接到什么，已经传到了美国，它们存在于文化中，无论人们是否知道他们的心灵可能有多深以及它可能在形而上学上连接到什么，都已经传到了美国，它们存在于文化中。无论人们是否知道他们的影响，荣格都是他们的许多影响之一。蒂莫西·Leary宣扬收听、调谐和脱落，Fritz Perls开发了格式塔疗法。威廉·赖希正在做后来成为（你知道的）生物能学、躯体工作的事情。每个人都在试图破解荣格所指出的这个密码，即如何在不发疯的情况下进入更深层的心理，同时也不试图假装我们在意识中只是自然选择的产物。即使那是它的起源，它也不是它的目的地。
And so some will succeed spectacularly, some will fail catastrophically, a lot of it will be very weird, most of it will be forgotten, and some poor souls will end up believing that they were raised by Satanists in Victoria, but that's another episode. So, final shot. Look at Jung at 80. He looks into the camera in his BBC interview and he says, In the end, the only events of my life worth telling are those when the imperishable world erupted into a transitory one. All of their memories have lost importance by comparison. The tragedy isn't that we fell from Eden when consciousness emerged. The tragedy is that we keep trying to go back instead of feeling our way forward. Jung knew the same precunius that kicked us out is the only bridge
因此，有些人会取得惊人的成功，有些人会彻底失败，其中很多会非常奇怪，大多数会被遗忘，一些可怜的灵魂最终会相信他们是由维多利亚州的撒旦教徒抚养长大的，但那是另一集了。所以，最后一个镜头。看看80岁的荣格。他在BBC的采访中看着镜头说，最后，我一生中唯一值得讲述的事件是那些不朽的世界爆发到短暂世界中的事件。相比之下，所有的记忆都失去了重要性。悲剧不在于当意识出现时我们从伊甸园坠落。悲剧在于我们不断试图回去，而不是去感受我们前进的路。荣格知道把我们赶出去的那个叛逆者是唯一的桥梁
home and the way that you make these networks fight is not by picking, the way that you solve the fight between the networks that make up consciousness and the brain is not by picking a side and killing the opposing side. It is about sitting with the tension of the opposites until a new paradox, a new religious and transcendental paradox, emerges that helps us synthesize the contradictions in the way that we think. However, those would have required America to sit with something that it is bad at sitting with because people are bad at sitting with this thing. Uncertainty. We need systems that make us know that we are doing it the right way, even if deep down we know that we are not.
回家的路，以及让这些网络战斗的方式不是通过挑选，解决构成意识和大脑的网络之间的战斗的方式不是通过挑选一边并杀死另一边。而是关于安于对立面的张力，直到一个新的悖论，一个新的宗教和超验的悖论出现，帮助我们综合我们思考方式中的矛盾。然而，这些将需要美国去适应一些它不擅长适应的事情，因为人们不擅长适应这件事。不确定性。我们需要一些系统，让我们知道我们正在以正确的方式做事，即使内心深处我们知道我们没有。
As David Tasey would point out in his book Jung and the New Age, the applications of Jungian psychology were largely distortions or superficial extensions of Jungian thought. They favored American positivity, avoidance, emotional avoidance or emotional enmeshment, consumerism, and simplified spiritual ideas. While Jung's original thought contained deep and complex, inclusive, culturally sensitive, and ethically grounded ideology, what largely would become associated with him, or would become endemic by people who didn't even really remember what they were aping, Jung provided something for America that marketed the capitalist system to generate profit through commodified spirituality and a largely avoidant psychotherapy. Jung's psychology would become
正如大卫·泰西在他的书《荣格与新时代》中所指出的那样，荣格心理学的应用在很大程度上是对荣格思想的扭曲或表面延伸。它们偏爱美国的积极性、逃避、情感逃避或情感纠缠、消费主义以及简化的精神思想。虽然荣格最初的思想包含深厚、复杂、包容、对文化敏感且具有道德基础的意识形态，但在很大程度上与他联系在一起的东西，或者被那些甚至不记得他们在模仿什么的人所形成的根深蒂固的东西，荣格为美国提供了一种通过商品化的灵性和大体上逃避的心理治疗来推销资本主义系统以产生利润的东西。荣格的心理学将成为
more associated with people who wanted to have magic powers than people who wanted to deal with their own shadow or seek a greater knowledge through his or awareness through his methods. And we would never do the thing that he had warned us the most strongly about, dealing with the hero myth in ourselves, confronting things like the prophet motive, confronting the ego and the empires that go along with it. And especially projection of a go along with it. An especially projection of a father myth of the perfect set of hierarchy and authority. Either a vision of the future that could not yet be, that was the good father with all of the power and all of the punishment, or as ourselves as long-suffering children who had to try and reform and participate in corrupt institutions. But of course while we enable them and also
更多地与那些想要拥有超能力的人联系在一起，而不是那些想要处理自己的阴影或通过他的方法寻求更高知识或意识的人。而我们永远不会做他最强烈警告我们的事情，即处理我们内心的英雄神话，面对诸如利润动机之类的事情，面对自我以及随之而来的帝国。尤其是随之而来的父亲神话的投射，即完美的等级制度和权威的完美结合。要么是对尚未实现的未来的愿景，那是拥有全部力量和所有惩罚的好父亲，要么是我们自己作为苦难的儿童，他们不得不尝试改革并参与腐败的机构。但当然，当我们使他们能够并且也
refuse to stop carrying water for their worst parts enough to change anything in order to try and be the long-suffering son who would heal the father, none of these were ever dealt with. None of these let us go inward. None of us let none of them let us manifest personal power in the way that Jung was calling for individuals to do. Buckle up and get ready for the American spiritual revolution. It was just a but-da but he still saw that you called God be in me, God be in me Let the one be, let the one be God be in me, God be in me Let the one be K.K.
拒绝停止为他们最糟糕的部分提供水源，以改变任何事情，从而试图成为治愈父亲的饱受苦难的儿子，这些都没有得到解决。这些都没有让我们向内看。没有一个人让我们以荣格呼吁个人去做的那种方式展现个人力量。系好安全带，准备迎接美国精神革命。它只是一个但达，但他仍然看到你叫上帝在我里面，上帝在我里面让这个成为一个，让这个成为一个上帝在我里面，上帝在我里面让这个成为一个 K.K.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh 3D Labyrinth Celeste Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Meet me in God, meet me in God Let the one be, let the one be Meet me in God, meet me in God Let the one be KK! Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Let the one be Let the one be Abel took his sheep to the altar right after Cain But her name was Dolly so you might see her again
哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦 3D迷宫塞莱斯特 哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，在上帝中遇见我，在上帝中遇见我 让这个成为一个，让这个成为一个 在上帝中遇见我，在上帝中遇见我 让这个成为一个 KK！噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦 让一个成为一个 让一个成为一个 亚伯在紧接着该隐之后把他的羊带到了圣坛上 但她的名字叫多莉，所以你可能会再次见到她
Let God be, let God be Let the one be Starbucks, Apple, Versace Let the one be, let the one be Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Let the one be, let the one be Let me be There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
让上帝存在，让上帝存在 让一个成为一个 星巴克，苹果，范思哲 让一个成为一个，让一个成为一个 哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦 让一个成为一个，让一个成为一个 让我成为这个 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。